what's now your best costume do you want  me to start okay  just at a comedy club and I knew that  there was like I think was like 500  bucks he can win it I was poor so I was  like I went to Walmart because I was  late in the game I had like three jobs I  was like her on the costume and I need  this money so I got an extra extra extra  large cow costume before I needed any  kind of excess really and and literally  the utters were dragging on the ground I  could I cut the nipples kids make us  dress up now which yeah Oh Mike yeah so  to mine we're you don't like family it's  a lot of pressure I love it no we do  thing baby things what did y'all do last  year we were we were trying the most  stores yeah oh my gosh these are not the  droids you're looking until you  subscribe to my youtube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this